[Music]
i like to write music so i have a ton of
voice memos and i wonder if you guys had
any tips for um like getting rid of
things that you create so whether that's
like voice memos or
um papers or like you written in school
or like random stuff that you've like
created like journal entries like all
that
let me ask you this you said melanie yes
what um
why do you want to get rid of them i
okay i think it's uh if i
if i like accidentally lost my phone or
something knowing and not really knowing
what's there
maybe so if i knew what was there it'd
be easier to let go of maybe if that
makes sense okay so you want to let go
of them and it's not organized
hey
and it's not organized because it's just
tons right right right and so well
the easiest way to organize your stuff
is to get rid of most of it
and then that way we don't have to
organize our things with digital clutter
it's a little bit different right so
digital clutter becomes a problem only
when it gets in the way there's so much
digital clutter out there don't you'll
never make it to the end of the internet
right it's so the internet is full of
all this color we have access to it but
we haven't accumulated on our own what
you're saying is something a little bit
different you you have some
accumulations whether it's on your phone
or computer or hard drives or anywhere
else and some of these things may be
useful to you but it seems to me the
reason you're asking this question is
because it feels to you either a like
they're getting in the way
or b
and this is the dangerous one so let's
be careful with this let's unpack it
b
you feel like you're supposed to get rid
of it
and i want to be careful with that
because
here's what happens
we
try to pursue happiness
through accumulating a bunch of things
right and so
if i just have the right well if i just
get things i'll be happy if i get more
things
i'll be happy didn't work you know
what's going to work
more things
and so we just try it for a decade or
two decades or four decades and
and we never get there in fact the
things start to the objects of our
desire start to become the objects of
our discontent they start making us
miserable and so then what do we do you
know what's going to make me happy if i
just get rid of the things
and so we let go of the things we rent a
dumpster and throw all our stuff in it
and it catches on fire or whatever and
we think that's going to make us happy
and then quite often people come to us
say hey i got rid of all my stuff why
aren't i why did it make me happy
oh because you thought getting rid of
the stuff was going to make you happy
that is just another form of consumerism
in a way
real consumerism is buying things
because you think they're going to make
you happy or complete
that's all consumerism is but the
reverse of that would be getting rid of
things because you think it's going to
make you happy or complete
right and so what do we do when we i got
rid of things here was the problem
though
i didn't have the right things
and so it wasn't the lexus it should
have been a mercedes
nothing wrong with either one of those
cars by the way but thinking those are
the the things are going to make us
happy that that's where it becomes a
problem and so
the reason it's a problem is because
happiness is something that's intrinsic
it can't be uncover it can't be pursued
it can only be uncovered
and so um
when i think about all those voice notes
if it's because you feel like you should
get rid of them i wouldn't worry about
them because that's someone else's
should that's not yours if however you
feel like oh they're actually getting in
the way of my life then yeah we could
talk about that so which is it for you i
mean i think it's probably a little both
a little bit of both
okay so in what ways are they getting in
the way for you well i just i can't find
like it's harder to find what i actually
want because there's too many
uh okay so
when you're doing these voice memos i
assume you're recording something and
you're just like i now i've recorded it
at least it's out of my head it's it's
somewhere so i don't have to worry about
it anymore but now it's causing a new
worry for you you just have this
abundance of of these voice notes well i
do i like writing songs so it's like the
first one is like not right so i do it
again and it's like oh it's a little
better and then another one
oh it's kind of cool to look back and
see how a song started and then what it
kind of gets to but sure sure it's like
a like a journal yeah yeah yeah songs
interesting yeah i mean you have to
determine how much value these things
have for you for me if they they extract
value for my life when they get in the
way so i could tell you that this book
went through nine different drafts yeah
did you keep them no
no
god that'd be ironic right
printed them out
oh
they're in the minimalist museum
no no but they were important they were
an important part of the process right
and so i can acknowledge that i can be
grateful for them and when i let go of
them i could say wow that really helped
draft four really helped me get to draft
five right and then it's really really
easy to click delete
thank you thank you yeah you know
man uh
we don't really know what we're doing
honestly
but we know what we're doing for us
and you know i put myself in your shoes
i think like
the the boundaries that josh and i talk
about a lot like that's really what
helps me so i do something similar where
i have this notepad
in my phone that i keep all these like
jokes or ideas for jokes or like these
beginnings of jokes because like my
my like side project sometimes someday
i'm gonna like do a five minute like
open mic night or something you know you
live in la you gotta do something you
gotta do some kind of performancing
right
but what i do is i i will go through
them uh you know once every six months
once every year in fact talking about it
right now is reminding me i'm like oh
man i haven't gone through those in a
couple months and i just refine the
things that i have so
i don't have an exact deadline on it but
you can put a deadline on it but it
makes me think about like uh
i don't know the spontaneous combustion
rule like that's something that josh and
i talk about a lot
so you can look at something you could
look at a book you could look at a note
or a voice memo and like ask yourself
like oh how how would i feel
if this spontaneously combusted right
now was gone like would i be devastated
or would i be a little bit relieved and
if you're relieved then that's like a
sure you know fire sign that maybe it's
okay to let that thing go but i think
with this whole journey of minimalism i
mean that's really
what josh and i have uh
really landed on just with these
boundaries like that's kind of you know
we made room for the important things
and to keep that room there we have to
set up these different boundaries and
guidelines so i think maybe something
even the spontaneous combustion will you
go through your phone and just listen to
a voicemail and be like how would i feel
like right now if i asked you like how
would it feel if you went to your phone
and all of a sudden like somehow i
magically deleted all those voice memos
would you be devastated all of them yeah
yeah like half of them
let's say fifty percent of the bad ones
but but okay okay so there are some in
there that you can totally use this with
yeah awesome i guess it's like photos
too like bat like oh it's like the ones
leading up to it you'd want to delete
them but get rid of that and i have a
hard time with that too so let's talk
about photos real quick because this is
something that applies to everyone in
here yeah the worst is like you go to
take a photo and you take seven of them
because you want to get like the best
one and then you don't you don't get rid
of the six that you don't want you keep
the seven yeah so i have i have two
boundaries with photo taking one is when
i take a photo
and this will seem crazy to some of you
i take only one photo
but we have these these devices allow us
to take 40 in a row it's like ah ding
ding ding and so what we're doing is we
just have
70 of the same photo
and then it's just like oh yeah i'll
like one of them and so i got this this
was actually a tip from a friend of mine
who's a who he's a photographer and he
uses film
actual film
and so he's like every picture i can't
just take seven of the same thing and
i'm like i can do that with my phone i
can just treat it like it's film and so
even if it's like blurry with my thumb
in it well that's the one i took
and um
and and it's awesome and it's been the
reason i do it is that constraint is
incredibly freeing because i've just
told myself oh now i don't have to go
take a bunch more photos try and get the
perfect photo i'm no longer i'm no
longer able to keep taking those in
addition to that whenever i have a
trigger anytime i get on an airplane
this could be any other thing for you
but we we tend to fly quite a bit i was
doing it yesterday when we were on
airplane i um i just go in and look at
my camera roll and delete anything that
i'm like i don't want to save this don't
want to save this don't want to save
this so having some sort of it could be
the first of the month could be the
trigger or it could be anytime i go to
this restaurant or whatever it is
anytime i'm here i'm going to spend 5 10
15 the first time it's to be you know
two hours on on the airplane that's why
i did on their plan i'm forced to just
go through all of them and those two
boundaries really helped me out and i
think you could extend that to your
voice memos as well thanks for your
question thanks for being here
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel one
hundred percent advertisement free